У цих, ніби космічних капсулах, дозрівають… українські діаманти.
Їх носять світові зірки. Втім, про них майже не знають у самій Україні.
Це один з наших цехів, де ми вирощуємо діаманти.
Тут стоять найбільші кубічні преси в світі.
Ми намагаємося тут виростити максимальні за розміром камені.
Висока температура та високий тиск - те, без чого неможливо
виростити діаманти. На заводі відтворюють природні умови росту.
Нам потрібна температура близько 1500 градусів.
Це приблизно, як температура біля поверхні Сонця.
І дуже високий тиск. Приблизно, як 640 африканських слонів,
які вам давлять на мізинець.
У таких умовах діаманти ростуть близько місяця,
після чого - роз'їжджаються по всій планеті.
Лабораторні діаманти в Україні почали вирощувати у 2015 році.
Саме тоді на базі київського ювелірного заводу "Ізумруд"
запрацював стартап, який не обіцяв ані популярності,
ані шалених прибутків. Утім, дорогоцінне каміння
українського виробництва швидко вподобали у Сполучених Штатах.
Завод до війни виробляв близько 10 тисяч карат на місяць.
Це досить великі об'єми. 100% цих діамантів йшли на експорт.
Ми працювали тоді переважно з Америкою -
з американським ринком. Також з європейським,
але, напевно, меншою мірою, тому що Європа досить консервативна,
й там ще не настільки поширені вирощені діаманти.
Напередодні повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну
справи компанії йшли вгору.
Тоді одразу кілька творінь Alcor-D потрапили до Книги рекордів Гіннеса
як найбільші вирощені діаманти - на 109 та 150 каратів.
Утім, після нападу РФ почалися проблеми з логістикою,
адже небо над Україною закрили, а згодом додалися труднощі
на виробництві через відключення світла.
Були кейси, коли ми просто втрачали всі партії, які були під ростом,
через відключення світла.
Вмикалися генератори, але інколи відключення були настільки довгими,
що не вистачало й генераторів. І було особливо сумно,
коли нам не вистачило буквально трьох хвилин між вимиканням
генератора та включенням світла. За ці кілька хвилин
вся партія була повністю знищена.
Та компанії все ж вдалося вийти на довоєнні об'єми виробництва.
Крім того, з'явилися й нові клієнти.
Окрім того, що ми відкрили представництво в Америці,
ми розширили географію наших продажів.
Тепер ми дуже багато співпрацюємо з Австралією та Новою Зеландією,
також з Великобританією та Японією.
Вироблені у лабораторіях діаманти конкурують з натуральними,
є вдвічі дешевшими і поступово завойовують ринок.
Крім того, вони вважаються "етичним" камінням, адже ростуть
без руйнування шарів землі та експлуатації праці.
Вони абсолютно ідентичні за своїми хіміко-фізичними властивостями
до добутого каміння. Мають ту ж міцність, ту ж гру світла - абсолютно все.
Лише інше походження. Воно вирощене людиною, а не видобуте з землі.
Тож популярність лабораторних діамантів викликає побоювання в Росії,
яка є лідером видобутку природних алмазів і прагне зберегти їхнє
домінування. Втім, нині найголовніша загроза для російського коштовного
каміння - не лабораторії, а 12-ий пакет санкцій, роботу над яким
завершують в ЄС. Як повідомив очільник європейської дипломатії Жозеп Боррель,
обмеження стосуватимуться і російських діамантів.
З 1 грудня вони збираються повністю заблокувати ввезення
російських діамантів на територію ЄС, а вже далі поступово
буде заборона на ввезення оброблених російських алмазів третіми країнами.
І це вкрай важливо. Адже, за словами експертів, треті країни,
а особливо Індія, відіграють ключову роль в обході РФ
вже існуючих "діамантових" санкцій.
Країна походження цього виробу - це вважається країна обробки,
а не країна-постачальник. І це легкий шлях для обходу санкцій.
Тобто РФ просто поставляє діаманти в Індію, а Індія продає без санкцій на ринки.
Також обходити існуючі обмеження Росії довгий час допомагає
поширене поняття  "змішані алмази".
Умовно кажучи, якщо у вас буде сто алмазів, з них 99 - з РФ, а один - з ПАР,
то це все буде вважатися алмазами змішаного походження.
І такі алмази не підпадають під санкції.
Очікується, що саме 12-ий пакет обмежень перекриє для Росії ці лазівки.
Якщо РФ дискваліфікують з діамантової гри - першим відчутним наслідком
для світового діамантового ринку буде зростання цін.
А далі - поступове заміщення природних діамантів на лабораторні.
Це буде стимулювати розвиток так званих лабораторних діамантів.
Вони поступово стають більш конкурентноздатними на ринку.
Так, вони дешевші у виробництві, є відмінності, які експерти зможуть
відрізнити, але з точки зору ювелірної галузі це не так критично.
Це вплине. Буде виходити заміщення за рахунок штучних діамантів.
Наразі сегмент вирощених діамантів займає близько 9%
від загального ринку, втім, експерти очікують на зростання частки до 25%
протягом наступних п'яти років.
І санкції проти РФ лише прискорять цей процес.
Тож за таких умов українських діамантів у світі ставатиме більше.
Київський завод має амбітні плани нарощування виробництва
й виходу на ринки нових країн. Чого не скажеш про перспективи
російських лабораторних діамантів.
Росія теж намагалася брати участь в цих перегонах.
Я знаю декілька заводів, які вирощують, але в них не так добре йдуть справи.
Діамантовий ринок досить вузький і весь побудований на особистих відносинах.
Тому навіть ці російські компанії, які намагаються зараз вийти знову на ринок -
їм всі відмовляють. І інститути, і інші компанії.
Крім того, діамантові санкції нанесуть відчутний удар по економіці Росії,
запевняє член Міжнародної експертної групи з санкцій Олександр Лисенко.
Адже щороку на діамантах, які у світі вже прозвали "кривавими",
країна-агресорка заробляє мільярди доларів.
Алмазна промисловість - це 3,8 млрд доларів. Це великі гроші.
І 100%, що за рахунок цих грошей РФ так само спонсорує війну в Україні.
Це і такий дипломатично-політичний зв'язок РФ з Індією та Ізраїлем.
Діаманти становлять основний товарообіг між ними і Росією.
Ми б дуже хотіли бачити ці країни союзниками України.
Для нас вигідно зробити менш цікавим для цих країн співробітництво з Росією.
І от, наприклад, якщо вони не зможуть торгувати
по одному з ключових елементів, то РФ однозначно стане для них менш цікавою.
Натомість для українського коштовного каміння відкриті всі дороги.
Уже є навіть так звані "амбасадори українських діамантів"
серед світових зірок.
Ось таку в нас обрала Ріанна. Це та каблучка,
яку ми зробили з нестандартним матеріалом й інкрустували діамантом.